well let's talk money a little bit can
we do that please let's talk money so
uh how long did it take for you to
actually start making money in comedy i
mean like legitimate money not like hey
here's a couple bucks kid drake joke but
like
money
i don't know 12 years third shot 11
years yeah oh yeah is you don't get in
it's going to take you 10 years of
getting by scraping by especially living
in manhattan yeah which is everything so
expensive but uh
yeah you got to love it and you
shouldn't get money that early because
you're not good
really so yeah how long does it take for
you to get good
at least eight or nine or ten years dude
this isn't like
[Laughter]
are you listening to this
you've been doing comedy how long about
a year a year wow
so what is she right now if i can baby
an infant and nobody what is she
yeah i think you're you're you know
you're you're newlywed you know it's all
fun and roses but uh it it's tough i
mean like do you have an hour of
material
you do yeah i started doing a headlining
holy well that's that's very advanced
but i'm coming from an entertaining
background
so the transition of like being on stage
the stage part is the easy part being
being um just the writing brain isn't
hard for me it's just actually the crowd
work and that uh-huh and in miami you
never know really your audience you're
just keeping adopting material and if
she's in miami
where where is miami on the like all
right that's
tough like new york is number one for
comedy yeah i agree la number two maybe
i don't know chicago
yeah maybe what's your top five cities
like that is the [ __ ] place to be
like our friend marcelo who you met he
moved out of miami because he was one of
the top guys in miami and now he's a
[ __ ]
grinder in new york oh really yeah it's
straight up for him exactly so where
what are the top places to do comedy new
york's number one i think austin might
be getting there i think chicago is
probably two la is good for getting
famous getting seen i don't think it's
great for cultivating an act you know a
lot of guys like jeselnik or bill burr
or whatever they started in new york and
then moved to la when they were already
good right so i think la's tough to
start out
but new york i'd say is great i think
austin might be coming up i don't know
what's the most underrated you're like
you wouldn't expect but kc
i don't know probably san francisco is
pretty great uh seattle denver
philly you ever done the comedy works in
denver one of the best clubs yeah i used
to perform there right that's where i
started yeah
yeah oh geez back in the day yeah well
it didn't work out so well and i gotta
[ __ ] host the financial show
well even conan now quit his [ __ ] to do
a podcast and apparently it's blowing up
huge yeah well conan is like just
i know we don't use the term goat but
that guy
he's my favorite he's he's awesome when
he does his little acting yeah if you
were still doing comedy you wouldn't be
as rich that's right that's a great
point that's true
thank you that is actually very true but
i'm just saying i'm not trying to [ __ ]
on a year into comedy you got to start
somewhere but i will say in 10 years
you're going to look back at this first
year and go ah
i'm not going to be able to watch
exactly by the way that was like the
most norm mcdonald's response
yeah whatever happened to him yeah i
don't know do you have do you have one
great uh nor mcdonald's story i don't i
only met him once and he was super sweet
couldn't have been nicer but i know a
great norm joke so he was on weekend
update and he did a joke about women
being bad drivers and the crowd went boo
and he goes well i have you know a woman
wrote that joke and they went oh okay
and he goes i'm kidding we don't hire
women
um and just kept his everything private
that he was dying for like 10 years in
this victimhood society he could have
pulled that cancer card at any moment
one of those things where he's being
recognized for his greatness yeah you
know after
after death that's what happened let's
get back to the money now all right so
it took you 10 years of grinding dealing
with drama nonsense [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] sure getting assaulted living on
nothingness yeah three times you got
mugged three times exactly who gets
mugged once not as much as twice three
times three times a charm
[Music]